the Joe Rogan experience mm-hmm yeah
yeah it's cool it's fun
I like what movies is that right now I
am worried that people are eventually
gonna all be living in some sort of a VR
world yeah I mean I feel like it's
designed to move that way right you know
what I'm saying
like you give people something and
they're gonna use it and they're gonna
get better yeah yeah yeah it wasn't have
extra feature yeah so it's like all
right you know I get it like [ __ ] have
you [ __ ] with any of that VR stuff
yeah VR is awesome do you ever do that
there's a thing outside of Disneyland
where you there's a VR game that you go
through you go to like this little like
they have a like a giant room and the
rooms set up for the was they called the
void yeah holy [ __ ] Lloyd VR and there's
a Star Wars one and there's a wreck it
Ralph one okay and they're hilarious I
mean you're walking around using heat
from fire pick up a plastic gun you're
shooting at stormtroopers mm-hmm and you
shit's crazy it's crazy and while you're
doing it you like this is just step one
exactly this is gonna be a saying yeah
there's one here in those pieces bits
and pieces like they already have more
you think that oh for show really one or
two percent I don't think that really
yeah why not because I think that what
they're showing you right now state of
the art they're selling it it's the best
again it's in competition it's getting
better and better all the time but
that's a good way to look at it because
they put it up myself enough on you know
no worries man yeah I just think these
people were very competitive yeah the
the the money is in getting the best
[ __ ] out the quickest okay and they're
all competing with each other so they're
putting out like the bootleg version and
letting somebody smarter test it work it
and make the better version then they'll
come back and do that later well that
definitely happens to I mean that's what
China does better than anybody
yeah I take some [ __ ] and just redo it
I'd be feeling like this is just my
eighth theories like VR right it might
be so [ __ ] dangerous that they don't
know like how it was enough yes
exactly so it's like they give us like
little bits and pieces of it to like let
us you know at least spoon feed it to us
so you don't kill us in the world just
go crazy and it's like you know what I
mean like yeah cuz they probably tested
it on somebody and they died like two
four you know what I mean oh for sure
yeah they look like oh [ __ ] we went too
far as I want let's like pull it back a
little bit and just give them that like
you said give them this version of it
you know what I mean but I feel like
there's more well I think when they when
you really don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on that's with military stuff I
think military stuff like weapons and
you know space ships and aircrafts that
they're developing we don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing they're doing
some [ __ ] that we have no idea right but
I think with things like consumer
electronics like technology I think what
you see is what you get I think this is
as good as they can do anything now
they're working on the newest best [ __ ]
right you know and that's coming around
there was they're always constantly in
development we're all competing against
each other there's no way they would
hold anything back
really yeah I don't think so damn I feel
like there's a phone that charges in two
seconds like okay the way you have it
out if you're in or war right and your
cellular device goes down it's like you
can't plug it in and charge it it has to
like happen quick right right so like
they have that it's in my opinion they
just don't give it to us but that all
that stuff the I could see your argument
because it's you're in a war they might
have better batteries like that the
military develop some new kind of
battery that's possible but there's so
much money in batteries mmm like there's
so much money if they had a better way
of doing it right if if Samsung came out
with a phone right charged 100 percent
in 30 seconds and it you eating Apple
would have to do we'd have to figure out
how to compete with them right they
would have that out I wouldn't hold on
to that they no one would hold on to
that Kyle was just dominating powerful
right it would dominate the mark it is
powerful but that happens that's what it
always happens me that's how
blockbusters out of business right you
know right right right that's why
there's no more Tower Records mmm
although that's dropping in our lifetime
yeah for show like 100% music isn't even
physical right like and I make music in
this dot it's not real right it's a
sound yeah it's a sound and [ __ ] you
know that is a crazy way to look at
music what is this
the r17 Pro which the company's latest
the fastest charging smartphone in the
world it advertises that 35 minutes is
all it takes to entirely fill up a dead
battery I was 7 months ago so so it's
probably faster they got something like
that for sure
35 minutes so what do you think they can
do look for a full battery I would say
that there's probably a hundred cell
phones out there that can charge in five
minutes there's not a million right as
they can't source that much they charge
more than this can well yeah I would say
like there's a military phone that they
might have a hundred of them okay around
the military but it's not mass per
ticket charge up in five minutes sure
for sure for sure and if this can do 35
minutes YouTube seven times faster
I mean to me doesn't sleep to me that is
normal this is energy that we're talking
about right right right bro like cars
still move off of gas like that should
like the Stone Age bro like [ __ ] smoogle
going electric you know what I'm saying
like that's not some spaceship [ __ ] so
they mean like at the end of the day
like they have this [ __ ] they just can't
give it to you because they they're
killing people testing it it's like it's
like food you know that I mean like they
have to approve this [ __ ] before it
comes out but they have a car that goes
here it just crashed into the wall you
know what I mean and somebody died in
and they're like well we can't put this
on the streets yet
it's like all that [ __ ] energy yeah like
what do you think they have a car that's
so fast they can't put it on the street
they have I just feel like
transportation in general you know I
mean communication transportation of
Technology the way we hear music the way
that we view things and [ __ ] like that
our whole experience tech technology
whatever the [ __ ] word is
we're being spoon-fed facetime you know
what I'm saying hmm it was like you used
to have to have the service to pet to
FaceTime now everybody can FaceTime you
know what I mean it's like people don't
even call each other no more they just
FaceTime so we feel like oh man we came
up this this was ba ba ba ba like we
feel good about that we feel excellent
about it but there's more I feel like
this just me I just feel like they're
just sitting on it you know and you know
waiting to give it to us
I don't think companies have any reason
to do that
then but the only reason to do that
would be to get rid of the stock of the
stuff authority selling that would be
the only reason because sometimes when
companies announce the new products
coming people stop buying the old
product like Corvette is having a
problem with that right now okay because
the Corvette let's call the zr1 right I
think yeah it's a demon it's ridiculous
you can go to a store and buy a car that
has that much horsepower but a lot of
people don't want to buy them because
there's a new Corvette coming out in
like a year right that's a mid-engine
total read new design I don't want to be
stuck with the old one gotcha
people get weird yeah that's true so in
that sense they might be holding out on
what they're about to be able to do but
like we saw with that foldable phone
that Samsung tried to come out with and
then they had to take it back mm because
it was so defective so many of them were
braking right a giant embarrassment and
they pulled the whole thing right and
now they're trying to rework it and
figure out what to do with it that
that's like if a company has something
like that happened and that's the number
two smartphone company in the were their
number one right Samsung's number one
Huawei's number two Apple's number three
mm-hmm that's the number one cell phone
manufacturer in the world and they got
that kind of a [ __ ] there's no way
they're not holding back anything I
don't think so I think they're trying to
sell the best [ __ ] they have right now
and then they're in development with the
next-level [ __ ] right now but as far as
like what they can bring to market what
they have is what they bring the market
and I think like those on-screen
fingerprint sensors they didn't use to
be able to do that now they can you just
touch the glass and it reads it mm-hmm
all that [ __ ] is like they're just
trying to get it dialed in to the point
where they could sell it to enough
people it doesn't break mm-hmm like like
that stupid folding did you see that
folding screen yeah it's like a [ __ ]
you could like it was a regular phone
but if
yeah yeah you know what fold opens like
an iPad iPad yeah yeah yeah that's just
stupid
but that thing kept breaking okay and
you know when it came out everybody's
like holy [ __ ] this is the future the
glass bends I think there's like like
you said there's like the the people who
just freaked out about whatever is new
right right and then there's like [ __ ]
that really moves the you know I'm
saying like like really change this [ __ ]
you know I'm sure and there's a huge
difference between those like you've got
the people who just want the new [ __ ]
and then you got [ __ ] who's
actually like doing [ __ ] that changes
things forever like streaming changed
music forever you know and I'm saying so
it's like mini discs and all of that
other stupid [ __ ] that people were
trying to do to change music it didn't
work you know what I mean and it didn't
exist
so it's like the one thing that stands
out and changes things forever that's
what people [ __ ] remember I
don't know if they're holding it or not
it is what it is but like there's some
smart [ __ ] who designed this
[ __ ] for us you know and I'm saying you
know and at the end of the day like the
dude you got people who just consume it
and they're just like oh man I'm here
for whatever whatever like you know what
I mean and then I feel like there's a
lot of people who understand it and know
how to play off of you know what I mean
those people's emotions and that's where
you get like you know I mean what we
have now
[Applause]